thank you
French president Emmanuel macron's
government invoked a special provision
of France's constitution on Thursday to
bypass parliament in a bid to push
through its controversial pension reform
s
[Applause]
the move received a frosty reception in
Parliament with lawmakers singing the
national anthem
[Applause]
[Music]
the use of article 49 of the French
Constitution allows the micro government
to avoid a parliamentary vote on the
bill which proposes raising the
retirement age
it comes after public sector workers
have walked off the job in droves
culminating in piles of trash building
up around the French capital
I'm in Paris with a view of the iconic
Eiffel Tower
but here's a scene that offers a less
romantic vision of the city
heaps of trash piled on the city streets
the garbage has not been picked up in
Paris for over a week this is in
response to the unpopular government
pension overhaul that has been proposed
by French president Emil Macon
Macomb has proposed overhauling
detention system he wants to raise the
legal retirement age by two years to 64
and make people work longer before they
can touch their pensions
unions are unhappy with the legislation
millions of workers have gone on strike
since January when the current bill was
first presented to Parliament
[Applause]
teachers train drivers in oil refinery
staff from across the country are among
those who have joined the strikes
recent polls showed nearly 70 percent of
people opposed to reforms but macron
says the changes are needed to protect
France's pension system from collapse
and to maintain control of government
expenditure
he has pledged to boost military
spending and wants to bring to National
deficits back in line with the European
Union's targets
France has one of the lowest rates of
retirees at risk of poverty in Europe
but this comes at a cost
France spends close to 15 percent of its
economic output on pensions that's
almost double what the U.S spends
to conference pension system is expected
to run a deficit of 1.8 billion euros in
that's said to keep increasing to 21.2
billion euros in 2035. as the population
ages the number of workers who fund each
pension check is shrinking the
government has ruled out raising taxes
to show up deficit saying that taxes in
France are already highs
results
suspension system in 2019 he proposed to
streamline France's 42 different state
pension plans which vary in retirement
age and income into one universal system
he also wanted to introduce bonuses and
penalties to encourage people to work
until the age of 64.
this led to strikes across the
transportation system which paralyzed
the country for weeks before the
government shared its plans as the
covid-19 pandemic struck but some
economists say to propose changes won't
keep the system afloat for long
many see the fights over pension as the
last 10 defense of France's social
welfare model
s
regression
assertive
procedures
[Music]
approved a controversial reforms on
March 11.
but the government struggled to couple
together enough votes for it to pass
through the low house of parliament the
National Assembly
comes at a high particle cost
protesters and opposition parties that
have fainted macron as an authoritarian
now have more ammunition to mobilize the
masses
demonstrators took the streets after
article 49 was invoked a number of
parties have said they will retaliate by
putting forward a no-confidence motion
if successful that would force the
government to resign
[Music]
foreign